In the U.S., more than half of drug overdose deaths now involves stimulants like methamphetamine and cocaine. There are no medications to treat stimulant addiction, but there is a behavioral treatment that works. Contingency management, which was developed by psychologists, involves giving people rewards such as money or gift cards in return for negative drug tests. It's a simple idea, yet despite decades of research showing the contingency management works, relatively few people who could benefit from it are able to access it. Now momentum is building to put it into practice at a larger scale. So why exactly do these interventions work? What are the psychological principles they're based on?
在美国，目前有一半以上的药物过量致死案例涉及兴奋剂，如甲基苯丙胺和可卡因。目前还没有治疗兴奋剂成瘾的药物，但有一种行之有效的行为疗法。权变管理由心理学家开发，其核心是向进行阴性药物检测的人提供金钱或礼品卡等奖励。这是一个简单的想法，尽管几十年的研究表明权变管理是有效的，但相对较少能从中受益的人能够获得它。现在，扩大其实施规模的势头正在增强。那么，这些干预措施究竟为什么有效？它们所依据的心理学原理是什么？
Can contingency management be used to treat other addictions such as alcohol or tobacco? How does it interact with other treatments? And what are the barriers to moving it from research labs to the real world at large scale? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today.
权变管理是否可以用于治疗酒精或烟草等其他成瘾？它与其他治疗方法如何相互作用？将其从实验室大规模推向现实世界的主要障碍是什么？欢迎收听“心理学对话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。今天我们请到了两位嘉宾。
First is Dr. Lara Kaufland, a licensed clinical psychologist and an associate professor at the University of Michigan Addiction Center. Her research aims to increase access to effective substance use prevention and treatments, especially for hard-to-reach and underserved populations. She's published more than 100 research articles, including work on contingency management interventions for stimulant use disorder, smoking cessation, and alcohol use disorder. My second guest is Dr. Michael McDonald, a psychologist and professor at the Elson S. Floyd College of Medicine at Washington State University. He's also director of the university's Prism Collaborative, which stands for promoting research initiatives in substance use and mental health, and is co-director of the Center for Rural Opioid Prevention, Treatment, and Recovery.
首先是劳拉·考夫兰博士（Dr. Lara Kaufland），她是一名持证临床心理学家，也是密歇根大学成瘾中心（University of Michigan Addiction Center）的副教授。她的研究旨在增加获得有效物质使用预防和治疗的机会，特别是针对难以触及和资源不足的人群。她已经发表了100多篇研究论文，其中包括关于兴奋剂使用障碍、戒烟和酒精使用障碍的权变管理干预措施的工作。我的第二位嘉宾是迈克尔·麦克唐纳博士（Dr. Michael McDonald），他是华盛顿州立大学埃尔森·S·弗洛伊德医学院（Elson S. Floyd College of Medicine at Washington State University）的心理学家和教授。他还是该校棱镜协作组织（Prism Collaborative）的主任，该组织致力于促进物质使用和心理健康方面的研究计划，并且是农村阿片类药物预防、治疗和康复中心（Center for Rural Opioid Prevention, Treatment, and Recovery）的联席主任。
Much of his research focuses on using contingency management to improve addiction treatment. He also partners with American Indian and Alaska Native communities to develop, test, and implement new treatment approaches for addictions. Thank you both for joining me. Glad to be here. Thanks for having us. Well, I'd like to start as we often do with the definition. I did say a little bit at the beginning in the intro about contingency management, but maybe you can flesh it out and explain how it works in practice.
他的许多研究都集中在使用权变管理来改善成瘾治疗。他还与美洲印第安人和阿拉斯加原住民社区合作，开发、测试和实施新的成瘾治疗方法。非常感谢两位能够接受我的邀请。很高兴来到这里。谢谢邀请我们。好的，我想像往常一样从定义开始。我在开场白里对权变管理做了一些简短的介绍，不过也许你们可以进一步阐述并解释它在实践中是如何运作的。
Contendency management is an interesting name because when I usually talk to people about it, they sort of think of talking about a crisis management strategy for a business. And of course, that makes sense. So contingency management, the reason that sort of has that name is the idea is that you're using contingencies or and it's really based on the theory of operant conditioning. So you're using sort of things from the environment to manage a behavior to help a person manage or change your behavior. So that's where it comes from.
权变管理（Contingency management）是一个有趣的名字，因为当我通常和人们谈论它时，他们会认为我们在谈论企业的危机管理策略。当然，这是合乎情理的。因此，权变管理之所以有这个名字，是因为其理念是你在使用权变因素（contingencies），它实际上基于操作性条件反射理论。所以，你是在使用环境中的某些事物来管理一种行为，以帮助一个人管理或改变他们的行为。这就是这个名字的由来。
Sometimes called motivational incentives is another term that we often use to describe contingency management. And, you know, psychologists developed a long time ago, the idea of operating conditioning. So that's the classic idea of sort of positive reinforcement. And positive reinforcement really is what contingency management. management's all about. So that's the idea that if you want to help somebody change the behavior, you want to increase a behavior or maintain it in the long run, the best way to do it, the most effective way to do it, is with reinforcers or what we more commonly call a reward.
有时被称为“动机性激励”，这是我们用来描述权变管理的另一个术语。你知道，心理学家很久以前就提出了操作性条件反射的概念。所以这是正强化（positive reinforcement）的经典概念。正强化实际上就是权变管理的核心所在。这就是说，如果你想帮助某人改变行为，你想要增加一种行为或从长远来看维持它，最好的方法、最有效的方法，就是使用强化物（reinforcers），或者我们更通常所说的奖励。
So, you know, if you think about examples of that, it might be that, you know, you are working to lose weight. Well, you might give yourself a reward once a week for maybe losing a pound or two. Or in my case, I wanted to run, get back into running. I'd been a runner for a long time. And so I started giving myself a dollar every day that I ran. And if I made it to 365, I got the full $365. And I've been running pretty much ever since. It's been about 20 years. So the idea of incentives or incentive-based interventions
所以，如果你想想这方面的例子，可能是你正在努力减肥。好吧，你可能每周给自己一次奖励，因为你可能减了一两磅。或者就我而言，我想跑步，重新开始跑步。我当了很长一段时间的跑步者。因此，我开始在我跑步的每一天给自己一块钱。如果我坚持了365天，我就能拿到全部的365美元。从那以后我几乎一直在跑步。大约已经20年了。所以激励或基于激励的干预措施的概念
or positive reinforcements-based interventions are really that they're a really successful way to help people change a behavior. As long as that behavior is objective and you can measure it. And as long as that person responds to the incentive or the reinforcer. So, of course, we want to give folks reward. that are rewarding, or reinforcers that are rewarding. So that's, the cadency measure really comes in this idea of positive reinforcement and that we can use it to help people make healthier choices. And in this case, with addiction, we're using objective behaviors like a urine test that a person
或者基于正强化的干预措施，确实是帮助人们改变行为的非常成功的方法。只要这种行为是客观的并且你可以测量。只要那个人对激励或强化物做出反应。所以，当然，我们要给人们奖励。那些具有奖励性质的东西，或者是具有奖励性质的强化物。因此，权变管理的真正切入点在于正强化的概念，即我们可以用它来帮助人们做出更健康的抉择。在这种情况下，针对成瘾问题，我们使用的是客观行为，比如一个人可以接受的尿液检测
could take that says, hey, I haven't used stimulants, stimulant drugs like cocaine or methamphetamine for the last few days. And when a person demonstrates that, then they would give them a tangible reward? So, and what we found is that this is a really effective way at how. helping people stop and in the long run, they're more likely to maintain abstinence or non-use from drugs and alcohol. These rewards are relatively small, and some people might find it surprising that something that modest, such as a gift card, could have such a big effect when the pull of addiction is so strong. Why does contingency management work? What are the psychological principles that underlie these interventions? Dr. Kaufman, maybe you want to take that one? Sure.
它可以说明，嘿，我在过去几天里没有使用兴奋剂，比如可卡因或甲基苯丙胺。当一个人证明了这一点，然后他们就会得到有形的奖励？所以，我们发现这是一种非常有效的方法，可以帮助人们戒除，从长远来看，他们更有可能维持戒断或不再使用毒品和酒精。这些奖励相对较小，有些人可能会觉得惊讶，像礼品卡这样微不足道的奖励，在成瘾诱惑如此强烈的情况下，怎么能产生这么大的影响呢？为什么权变管理会有效？这些干预措施背后的心理学原理是什么？考夫兰博士，也许你想谈谈这个？当然。
And I want to say that Dr. McDonald did a really wonderful job, sort of describing contingency management, which on its face is a relatively simple idea. And that is really the psychological principle that we want to get at here, which is that as humans, we all respond to reinforcement. We respond to addaboys and we respond to incentives in our jobs. And contingency management is really thinking about that in the addiction space. And this is sort of important because a lot of our addiction care, hasn't so much focused on making sure that we are really encouraging our treatment facilities, our providers to think about rewarding people. One of our colleagues says something that I love, catching people doing good is not always our model within the addiction care space. And so I think of CM as counterbalancing really the powerful reinforcing effects of drug use
我想说的是，麦克唐纳博士在描述权变管理方面做得非常出色，表面上看，这是一个相对简单的概念。这确实是我们这里想要探讨的心理学原理，那就是作为人类，我们所有人都会对强化做出反应。我们对赞赏做出反应，我们对工作中的激励做出反应。而权变管理实际上就是在成瘾领域思考这个问题。这非常重要，因为我们的许多成瘾治疗，并没有那么关注确保我们真正鼓励我们的治疗机构和提供者去考虑奖励人们。我们的同行中有人说过一句话我很喜欢，“捕捉人们做得好的地方”并不总是我们在成瘾治疗领域的常规模式。因此，我认为权变管理实际上可以起到平衡作用，通过将面向康复的行为变得即时具有奖励性，来抵消药物使用的强大强化效果
by making recovery-oriented behaviors immediately rewarding. And that immediately rewarding part is really important. We sometimes talk about this field as being related to behavioral economics and this being an intervention that came from behavioral economics because it is helping us understand how an immediate reinforcer, like a relatively modest amount of money, let's say $10, could today actually serve to prevent me from using a really potent substance like methamphetamine. And it does. And a big important piece there is that immediacy not telling someone, hey, you can get $10 in a year. that is not merely potent enough to change immediate behavior. But you can get $10 today, and that is really meaningful to a lot of people. And so that is sort of the underlying construct. I don't know, Dr. McDonald, if you'd like to add to that.
这种即时奖励的部分非常重要。我们有时将这个领域与行为经济学联系起来，认为这是一种源自行为经济学的干预措施，因为它帮助我们理解即时强化物（例如相对适度的金钱，比如10美元）今天如何能够真正起到阻止我使用像甲基苯丙胺这样强效物质的作用。而且它的确做到了。其中一个非常重要的部分就是“即时性”——不是告诉某人，嘿，你可以在一年后得到10美元。那不足以改变当下的行为。但是你今天就能得到10美元，这对许多人来说真的很有意义。这就是潜在的结构。我不知道麦克唐纳博士是否想补充这一点。
No, that was a great description. And so many of the principles we talk about, I think the one thing I would add is just if it's okay to talk about a really cool study. And it's been a series of studies where they sort of came up with this finding that really was a small amount of money that could help a person change. make a decision around their substance use. And so there's been a number of studies done like this. This is one that was done in the 90s.
不，那是一个很好的描述。我们谈论的很多原则，我想我能补充的一点是，如果可以谈论一个非常酷的研究的话。这是一系列研究，他们得出这样一个发现：确实是一小笔钱就能帮助一个人做出改变，围绕他们的物质使用做出决策。因此，已经有很多类似的研究。这是一项在90年代完成的研究。
So you sort of have to adjust it for inflation. And they've done this with nicotine, cocaine, alcohol, kinds of different substances. But what this study was, I think, on cocaine. So they had actually got approval for all this stuff. So it totally was legit and allowed. And so they had people come into a facility and they had cocaine. They legally obtained cocaine. And they put the line of cocaine in front of a person who was,
所以你得根据通货膨胀进行调整。他们对尼古丁、可卡因、酒精等不同物质都做过这种研究。但这项研究的内容，我认为是关于可卡因的。所以他们实际上为所有这些事情获得了批准。所以这完全是合法且被允许的。因此，他们让人们进入一个设施，他们有可卡因。他们合法获取了可卡因。他们把一小条可卡因放在一个被识别为使用可卡因的人面前，
who identified as a person who used cocaine. And they said, hey, do you want a line, you can pick right now, a line of cocaine or five cents. 80% of people pick the line of cocaine over the five cents, right? Makes sense. Yeah. Then they bumped it up to a dollar and they got closer to 50-50. But once you just bumped it up to two American dollars from 1990,
他们说，嘿，你想要一条吗？你现在可以选，一条可卡因还是五美分。80%的人选择可卡因而不是五美分，对吧？这说得通。是的。然后他们把金额提高到一美元，结果接近五五开。但一旦你把它提高到1990年的两美元，
about 80% of the time people would pick the $2. and so over that line of cocaine. And so I was just sort of riffing off of a Dr. Coggle and said about the immediacy. So to me, I think about this as an opportunity. When you're a person who has a substance use disorder, when you're really struggling, when you've lost all those other things in life that really matter to you that are really are rewarding to you or you lost many of those things, sometimes that drug becomes your only reward and it's your only opportunity to sort of have positive feelings or to avoid your problems
大约80%的时间人们会选择那两美元，而不是那条可卡因。所以我只是顺着考格林博士（注：此处采访中口误或拼写变体）关于即时性的说法展开。对我来说，我认为这是一个机会。当你是一个患有物质使用障碍的人，当你真正苦挣扎时，当你失去了生活中所有那些对你真正重要、真正对你有奖励意义的东西，或者你失去了许多这些东西时，有时那个毒品就成了你唯一的奖励，成了你获得积极感受或逃避问题的唯一机会，
or cope with your problems. And so when I think about contingency management is we're offering a small, tangible opportunity to pick something else besides substance use. And when we do do that, most people will choose that tangible non-drug incentive over the drug when putting that circumstance where they can make that choice.
或是应对你的问题。因此，当我想到权变管理时，我们提供了一个小的、有形的机会，让人在物质使用之外选择别的东西。当我们这样做时，在被置于可以做出这种选择的环境中时，大多数人都会选择这种有形的非毒品奖励，而不是毒品。
So I just want to put out there that the SAMHSA, the Substance Abuse and Mental Health Services Administration, but last year increased the incentive cap to $750 per patient per year. How has that changed the ability of providers and states to implement CM? That's a great question, and that was an exciting development. I think there's been bipartisan support over the last 12 years or so to sort of stimulate contingency management research or practice to start to figure out ways to get it out there. And so that $750 is important because it allows states and tribes who are either received the state opiate response,
我只想指出，美国滥用药物和精神健康管理局（SAMHSA）在去年将每位患者每年的奖励上限提高到了750美元。这如何改变了提供者和各州实施权变管理的能力？这是一个很好的问题，这是一个令人兴奋的发展。我认为在过去的12年左右里，两党一直支持刺激权变管理的 RESEARCH 或实践，开始寻找将其推广出去的方法。因此，750美元很重要，因为它允许获得州阿片类药物响应补助金的州和部落，
grant or the tribal response grants, which total about $1.5 billion, that allows them to spend money on incentives. Before it was only $75, and we knew that was not an effective dose for a period of time. So, you know, what we know is that $750 is pretty close to what we think an evidence-based dose of contingency management looks like, because you not only need to have an amount, so that dollar amount, like Dr. Coggin was talking about $10 or so, let's say, for the first urine test you submit, and getting that reward when it's negative, that's important to have the right dose at that in particular time,
或部落响应补助金（总计约15亿美元），将资金用于奖励。在此之前只有75美元，我们知道在一段时间内这不是一个有效的剂量。所以，你知道，我们知道750美元非常接近我们认为的权变管理的循证剂量，因为你不仅需要有一定的金额，比如像考格林博士谈到的10美元左右，比方说，针对你提交的第一次尿液检测，并在结果为阴性时获得该奖励，在特定时间提供正确的剂量这很重要，
but you also need to have the right duration. We really know that three to six months of contingency management is really what's needed. So to be able to give that $10 out every time a person has a negative urine test and to maintain that intervention for three months, really, yeah, 750 is pretty close to where we think you need to be at. So that was really great.
但你还需要有正确的持续时间。我们确实知道，持续三到六个月的权变管理才是真正需要的。因此，能够在一个人每次尿液检测呈阴性时发放这10美元，并将该干预措施维持三个月，真的，750美元非常接近我们认为你需要达到的水平。所以这真的很棒。
The challenge we've got still, though, so I was a little worried when they did that because, you know, Dr. Codlin and my team and other teams, only a few teams in the United States who are training people to do contingency management. So we're a little anxious when that happened, but it didn't really open the floodgates the way we think it would because those grants had already been allocated. So, you know, as a state administrator of a big opioid response grant, I'm supporting other, with that SAMHSA grant, I'm supporting other programs already. We need more treatment for opioid use disorder, which we know
不过我们仍然面临的挑战是，当他们这样做时我其实有点担心，因为你知道，考格林博士和我所在的团队以及其他团队，美国只有少数几个团队在培训人们进行权变管理。所以当那件事发生时我们有点焦虑，但它并没有像我们想象的那样打开闸门，因为这些补助金已经分配好了。所以，你知道，作为一个大型阿片类药物响应补助金的州管理员，我已经在用SAMHSA的补助金支持其他项目了。我们需要更多的阿片类药物使用障碍治疗，我们知道丁丙诺啡（buprenorphine）这种药物是治疗该病最好的方法。所以我们需要在那方面进行投资。因此这些资金已经花出去了。所以我们没有得到我们预期的那么大的反应，但这真的很令人兴奋，因为这是第一次将资金提供给各州和部落，以便能够开展循证的权变管理。我们必须共同弄清楚他们将从哪里找到这笔资金，即他们如何能够抽出一些资金并重新分配以支持这一点。简短的回答是，我们需要更多的成瘾干预，并在总体上为成瘾干预提供更多资金。这些项目现在在哪里可以找到？我的意思是，并非每个州都在这样做。那么如果人们需要，在哪里可以获得权变管理呢？
buprenorphine, which is a medication is the best way to treat that. So we need to invest way there. So those monies are already being spent. So we haven't had as a big of a response as we were anticipating, but it's really exciting because it's for the first time that that money is available to states and to tribes to be able to do evidence-based contingency management. We sort of have to figure out together where they're going to find that money in terms of how they can take some money and move it around to be able to support this. We just need more addiction intervention would be my sort of short response and more funding for addiction intervention across the board. where are these programs available right now? I mean, every state is not doing this. So where can people access contingency management if they need it?
第一个对权变管理进行大规模推广并真正成为领导者的项目是退伍金健康管理局（Veterans Health Administration），该局于2011年开始实施。现在，想想看，他们已经在100多个设施和医疗健康中心提供权变管理几十年了，这真是令人难以置信。在此之后，各州采取了多种不同的途径在州一级提供权变管理，通常是针对医疗白卡（Medicaid）受益人，这一群体受到的打击尤为严重，而且往往没有得到最能让他们受益的成瘾护理。这方面的领头羊是加利福尼亚州。他们获得了所谓的医疗白卡1115示范豁免批准。然后我还要说，麦克唐纳博士的家乡华盛顿州也获得了批准，还有其他一些州。这为各州提供了一种途径，这是一项庞大的事业，令人兴奋且具有开创性的工作，可以在社区物质使用障碍诊所中，向任何符合医疗白卡资格、患有兴奋剂使用障碍（经常使用甲基苯丙胺或可卡因，且严重干扰了其生活）的人提供权变管理
The first program to do a really big rollout of contingency management, and we're really leaders, was the Veterans Health Administration, which started in 2011. Now, really think about that that they've been delivering contingency management at over 100 facilities, medical health centers for decades now, which is incredible. Following that, states have taken a few different routes to provide contingency management at state levels, often to Medicaid beneficiaries, which are a population that's particularly hard hit and oftentimes doesn't receive the addiction care that most would benefit them. And so a leader in that has been California. They got what's called a Medicaid 1115 demonstration waiver approved. And then I'll say Dr. McDonald's home state also got one. in Washington, and there's been a few others. This is provided a way for states, and this is, this is a big undertaking, exciting and really groundbreaking work to provide contingency management
。所以这些项目正在进行中。其他一些州也采取了不同的方法，在这里，我在密歇根州，密歇根州也有一个针对患有兴奋剂使用障碍或阿片类药物使用障碍的医疗白卡受益人的项目，该项目使用的是阿片类药物诉讼和解资金。因此，确实，其他州也在效仿这种模式，例如佛蒙特州和缅因州的模式。因此我认为各州，越来越多地我们看到这种趋势，各州真的希望成为其中的一部分，真的看到权变管理是我们应对我们面临的日益严重的兴奋剂使用挑战的一种方式。
in community substance use disorder clinics to anyone who is a Medicaid beneficiary who qualifies with a stimulant use disorder, so it's using methamphetamine or cocaine often in a way that's really getting in the way of their life. So those programs are ongoing. A few other states have taken And other approaches here in, I'm in Michigan, here in Michigan, we have a program also for Medicaid beneficiaries who have stimulant use disorder or opioid use disorder that uses opioid settlement funds. And so really, and other states are also following that, such as Vermont and Maine model. And so I think states, increasingly, we're seeing this sort of versioning of states really wanting
在这个国家当前的背景下，我们终于看到阿片类药物相关的过量致死人数有所缓解，我们发现我们确实需要关注这样一个事实：许多人正在使用多种不同类型的物质，而这就是我们手头对兴奋剂使用障碍有效的疗法。因此，我们看到各州对此产生了浓厚兴趣，付款方、保险付款方也对确保其计划中的个人能够获得我们在科学上证明有效的服务产生了兴趣。老实说，这是一个非常令人兴奋的时刻，看到资助这项工作的不同途径，以及不同的庞大系统——州立、国家级医疗系统——都在采用权变管理，并弄清楚当我们在不再处于随机对照试验（90年代和2000年代初的大部分工作都在那里进行）的环境中时，这在现实世界中是什么样子的。我想问一个关于这种疗法适用人群的问题。现在，你提到了医疗白卡，所以我们谈论的是收入不高的人。对于来到权变管理项目的人来说，他们必须基本上处于较低的社会经济阶层才能让这起作用吗？还是说你也可以是一个赚大钱的成功商人，每次给10或15美元依然会改变你的行为？这是我们经常遇到的问题。谢谢你，金。所以没有证据
to be a part of this, really seeing that contingency management is a way for us to address the rising stimulant use challenges that we face. in the context right now as a country where we're actually finally seeing some relief and opioid involved overdose deaths, we're finding that we really need to attend to the fact that many are using multiple different types of substances, and this is what we have that works for stimulant use disorders. So we're seeing states get really interested, also payers, insurance payers getting interested in making sure that their individuals that are on their plans are getting the services that we know through the science work. So it's a really exciting time, honestly, to see both
表明你的社会经济地位能预测你是否会对权变管理做出反应。我是从这样一种视角来看待这个问题的：有些人对小型的强化物非常积极，比如轻拍一下后背就能让他们行动起来，或者他们会为一个美元做某些事情，这太神奇了，而另一些人则完全不感兴趣。这里面存在一些个人因素。我知道人们正在研究这一点，但这些似乎更多地与你的社会经济地位无关，而是可能与你的决策过程以及你如何看待任何特定决策的成本与收益有关。所以，这也引发了、某种程度上引发了
the different pathways for funding this work and the different large systems, state, national health systems, taking contingency management up and figuring out what this looks like in the real world when we're no longer in a randomized control trial, which is where a lot of the work was in the 90s and early 2000s. I want to ask a question about the types of people for whom this works. Now, you mentioned Medicaid, so we're talking about people who are not making a lot of money. Is it necessary for a person who comes into a contingency management program to basically be on a lower socioeconomic level for this to work, or can you be, you know, a successful business person making a whole lot of money and still getting 10 or 15 bucks a shot is going to change how you behave? That is a common question that we get. Thank you, Kim. So there's no evidence
一个更大的问题，这就回到了这一点，也就是我们需要弄清楚谁会在什么时候做出反应。事实上，我们知道你的成瘾越严重，你对任何特定治疗做出反应的可能性就越小。例如，最好的预测指标（这也是我的团队在研究中做很多工作的地方）是你可能拥有的生物标志物的水平，或者比如尿液检测。尿液检测，如果是阳性的，这就预示着你在权变管理中的表现会较差。这也是你在任何其他物质使用干预中表现如何的预测指标。因此，我认为我们开始真正审视这些因素，但社会经济地位似乎并不是其中之一。现在我正在全国范围内做一个关于酒精使用障碍权变管理的虚拟研究。我们有来自广泛社会经济地位和各种地点的各种各样的人。这项研究发现的主要事情是，只有大约四分之一的人以前曾接受过酒精问题的治疗。因此我认为这是一个更大的问题，人们只是，你知道，无论他们正在挣扎的是什么物质，都在真正寻求帮助。正如考格林博士刚才所说，这是一种积极、赋权且有趣的方式，可以支持人们做出行为改变。你知道，如果我们谈论将权变管理用于，比如说酒精使用障碍或戒烟，我的意思是，你们如何
that your socioeconomic status predicts whether or not you respond to contingency management. And I think about that sort of in a perspective of sort of some people are very motivated. by a small reinforcer, like a small repad on the back, gets them going, or they'll do something for a, for, you know, a dollar and it's amazing, where other people are just like absolutely not interested. This does it, I'm not, I'm not. So there's some individual factors there. I know people are studying that, but, but those seem to be more, not related to your socioeconomic status, but maybe made to your sort of decision-making process and the way you sort of see cost versus benefits of any particular decision. So, but, and it raises, sort of, and it raises, sort of,
衡量某人在特定的一周内是否出现反复？你知道，我的意思是，你们怎么知道我昨晚喝了酒？我可以讲讲酒精方面，也许考格林博士可以讲讲吸烟方面，因为我认为这是一个很好的分工。那我简短一点。这是我在权变管理领域的专长，体现在我们开展的研究项目中。在2000年代初，曾有过一项针对酒精权变管理的非常精彩的出色研究。他们每周进行几次呼气测试。当然，当他们分析结果时，他们发现人们每周提交两次阴性呼气测试的可能性要大得多，但他们也发现这些人经历过解毒、排毒治疗，他们在急诊室里，他们喝过酒，
of a larger question, which comes back to this, which is it doesn't, we need to figure out who responds and when. And actually, we know that the more severe your addiction, the less likely are to respond to any given treatment. So, for instance, the best predictor, and this is where my team does a lot of work in research, is sort of the level of a biomarker you might have, or like, let's say a urine test. A urine test, if it's positive, that's a predictor that you're going to do less well in contingency management. It's also a predictor of how well you're going to do in any other substance use intervention. And so I think we're starting to really look at those factors, but socioeconomic status does not seem to be one. And right now I'm doing a virtual study across the
他们酒驾被抓并面临指控，所以他们并没有捕捉到他们所有的酒精使用情况。因此在我们的案例中，我们使用了一种名为乙基葡萄糖醛酸酯（ETG）的尿液测试，它可以检测大约三到五天的使用情况，这与兴奋剂测试非常相似。这就是标准的门诊权变管理模式，你每周去诊所两次并提供尿液样本。因此我们已经证明使用这种方法的权变管理效果很好。我们还在使用另一种生物标志物，即基于血液的生物标志物，人们可以自己采集一份简单的血液样本然后将其寄往实验室。通过这种被称为磷脂酰乙醇（PEth）的生物标志物，我们可以检测长达一个月的物质使用情况。因此，
country of contingency management for alcohol use disorder. And we have people across the wide, wide range of socioeconomic status and all kinds of locations. The main thing that we're finding in this study is that only about a quarter of people have ever gotten treatment for the alcohol problems before. And so I think that's a bigger thing that people are just, you know, really looking for help no matter what their substance that they're struggling with is. And this is a, like Dr. Cogden was saying earlier, this is a positive, empowering and fun way to support people in making behavior change. You know, if we're talking about using contingency management for, say, alcohol use disorder or smoking cessation, I mean, how,
这赋予了我们这样一种能力：我们可以让一个人开始参加一个项目，在这个项目中我们可能更频繁地使用生物标志物来监测或测量他们的物质使用。但随后有了这种血液生物标志物PEth，一旦一个人建立了一段戒断期并且觉得自己做得很好，我们实际上就可以减少监测频率，让他们只需每月来一次或每月与我们见一次面。这样对他们来说就方便多了，我们可能能够将干预维持更长时间。这就是它在酒精方面的运作方式。我想请考格林博士谈谈烟草。好的。所以在烟草领域，我们所知道的是，权变管理确实能帮助人们成功实施戒烟尝试。它还可以让人们
do you measure whether somebody is backsliding in a given week? You know, I mean, do you know that I had a drink last night? So I can talk about the alcohol side and maybe Dr. Coggin can talk about smoking, because I think that's a good split. So I'll be really quick. So that's my niche in contingency management in terms of sort of our research program that I do. There was a study done, a wonderful, great study done in the early 2000s on contingency manager for alcohol. And they did breathalizers a couple times a week. And of course, when they analyzed the results, they found that people were way more likely to submit a negative breath test two times a week, but they also found that they were a detox, sickification treatment, and they were in the ER, and they had drunk, you know,
更有可能在现在就愿意进行戒烟尝试。因此，如果你问吸烟的人，嘿，你想戒烟吗？十有八九，绝大多数人都会说，是的，我不想抽烟。我们围绕这一点开展了非常成功的公共健康运动。人们知道吸烟对他们有害。然而，如果你问人们，你想今天戒烟吗？你愿意今天戒烟吗？人们对现在就准备好这样做不太确定。然而，如果你把它放在这样一个背景下：我们正在做这个项目，我们有这个权变管理项目，你实际上可以通过戒烟赢得奖励，突然间人们就会觉得，好吧，这有助于推动他们的决定，让他们觉得“好吧，我们现在就做”。然后我们看到人们成功的可能性超过两倍
and they'd drive them by and they'd influence charges, so they weren't catching all their alcohol use. And so in our case, we use a urine test called Ethelguconoride or ETG, and that can detect use about three to five days, which is pretty similar to a stimulant test. And that's the standard sort outpatient contingency management model as you come into a clinic two times a week and give a urine test. And so we've shown that contingency management using that works really well. We're also using another biomarker, which is a blood-based biomarker, that people can self-collect an easy blood sample and then send it off to a lab. And we can detect with that biomarker, which is called phosphatidyl ethanol or path, we can detect someone's substance use for up to a month. And so what
使用权变管理成功戒烟的可能性要大得多，即使我们将它与尼古丁替代疗法和我们已知也有帮助的戒烟药物结合使用也是如此。因此，这是我们可以真正认真对待的一种方式。我们知道，吸烟的成本是我国最大的可预防的导致死亡和疾病的原因。它对我们的医疗系统以及人们最终需要的服务类型成本很高。我们有一种真正帮助他们戒烟的方法。而且我们可以远程完成，这也许是最重要的部分。因此，金，回答你的问题，我们可以频繁地检测某人是否在吸烟，而不需要要求他们一直去诊所，因为我们可以通过呼出气体来完成。这只需对着一个小设备吹气即可，
that gives us the ability to do is to sort of start a person in a program where we're more frequently maybe monitoring or measuring their substance use with a biomarker. But then with this blood biomarker path, we can actually move once a person has established a period of abstinence and they feel like they're doing really well, we can move it to be less frequent so that they can come in just once a month or meet with us once a month. And then it's much more convenient for them and we might be able to keep the intervention going longer. So that's how it works for alcohol. And I'll like Dr. Cog would talk about tobacco. Sure. So in the tobacco space, what we know is that contingency management really helps people be successful in a quit attempt. And it can also make people
我们可以把它发给人们。它根据一氧化碳水平告诉我们他们最近是否抽过烟。因此，这是一种人们可以随着时间推移进行监测的方法。人们真的很喜欢查看他们的CO水平如何变化，比如小时对小时，然后他们可以获得奖励。因此，这是一种非常好的方式，我们可以以一种类似于戒烟热线的人口健康模型的方式，支持人们真正进行严肃且强有力的戒烟尝试，因为戒烟极具挑战性，我们真的需要全力以赴。我们要休息一会儿。回来后，我和考格林博士以及麦克唐纳博士将继续讨论权变管理的运作方式以及它对谁
be more likely to be willing to make a quit attempt now. So if you ask people who smoke cigarettes, like, hey, do you want to quit, eight out of ten of them, the vast majority are going to say, yes, I don't want to smoke cigarettes. We've had a very successful public health campaign around that. People know they're bad for them. Yet, if you ask people, do you want to quit today? Are you willing to quit today? People are less sure they're ready to do it right now. However, if you put that in the context of we're doing this program, we have this program, this contingency management program, and you can actually earn rewards for quitting, suddenly people are like, okay, that helps to push their decision towards like, okay, let's do it now. And then we see that people are more than two times
最有效。嗨，老兄。我是Priceline谈判专家。我是如何协商到如此多伟大的旅游优惠的？我的终极小工具。Priceline应用程序。它拥有酒店优惠、航班优惠、租车优惠，
more likely to be successful in quitting using contingency management, even when we add it to things like nicotine replacement therapies and smoking cessation medications that we also know are helpful. So this is a way that we can sort of be really serious. We know that the cost of smoking is the largest drive preventable cause of death and disease in our country. It's very costly on our healthcare system and the type of services that people end up needing. And we have a way to really help them quit. And we can do it remotely, which is maybe the most important part. So Kim to your question, we can measure if someone's smoking frequently without needing to ask them to go to a clinic all the time, because we can do it through exhaled breath. So it's just blowing into a little
所有这些优惠打包在一起。优惠。比赛日优惠。音乐会之旅优惠。没有人比Priceline提供更多优惠。等等，还有更多。该应用程序允许您按街区、氛围、星级以及游泳池、水疗中心和海滩等便利设施对酒店进行筛选。等等，我还没说完。
device so we can give to people. And it tells us if they smoked recently or not based on the carbon monoxide levels. So this is a way that people can sort of monitor it over time. People really like to be all see how their CO levels change, like, hour to hour, and then they can get rewards. And so it's a really nice way that we can sort of, in a population health model, sort of like how quit lines work, be able to support people and really making a serious robust quit attempt, because quitting smoking is extremely challenging, and we really need to give it our all. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk more with Dr. Coughlin and Dr. McDonald about how contingency management works and for whom
别打断我。没人去汉克的店是为了看电子表格。他们是为了美味的披萨。不过最近，店里一直很安静。所以汉克决定重新推出1美元的披萨切片。他请Microsoft Excel中的Copilot查看他的销售额和成本，以帮助他了解自己是否负担得起。Copilot向汉克展示了资金的去向，
it works best. Bonjour, compadre. It's the Priceline negotiator. How do I negotiate so many great travel deals? My greatest gadget. The Price Line app. It's got hotel deals, flight deals, rental car deals,
以及哪些小花头让1美元披萨切实可行。现在，汉克的店门前排起了长队。汉克制作披萨。Copilot处理电子表格。在M-360.copilot.com/work了解更多信息。权变管理通常与其他治疗方法结合提供吗？我的意思是，你提到了一些可以与戒烟一起做的事情，但如果我们谈论的是
all of those deals in a bundle. Deals. Game Day deals. Concert trip deals. No one deals more deals than Price Line. Hold your horses. There's more. The app lets you filter hotels by neighborhood, vibe, star level, and amenities like pools and spas and beach fronts. Wait, I'm not done.
使用安非他命和阿片类药物的人，像认知行为疗法（CBT）这样的方法有帮助吗？还是说单靠它自己就行？它可以是双向的。当然，权变管理可以单独提供，不需要同时提供心理治疗，例如认知行为疗法。但在我们将其与认知行为疗法进行比较的试验中，它只是改善了治疗结果。所以这是一个并不存在禁忌症的例子。我们还研究了这一点，虽然不是我和麦克唐纳博士亲自研究的。该领域已经研究了我们的阿片类药物使用障碍药物。同样，权变管理改善了治疗结果。
Stop cutting me up. No one goes to Hank's for his spreadsheets. They go for a darn good pizza. Lately, though, the shop's been quiet. So Hank decides to bring back the $1 slice. He asks co-pilot in Microsoft Excel to look at his sales and costs to help him see if he can afford it. Co-pilot shows Hank where the money's going
当我们谈论阿片类药物使用时，阿片类药物使用障碍药物是我们的首选治疗方法，就像权变管理是我们的兴奋剂使用障碍首选治疗方法一样。因此我的建议是：当然，阿片类药物使用障碍药物加上权变管理是有帮助的。当谈到兴奋剂时，我的建议是权变管理绝对应该成为治疗组合的一部分。加入认知行为疗法是惊人的。人们喜欢学习应对压力和管理问题思维的技能，除了因为康复导向行为而给予奖励之外，这是一个很好的
and which little extras make the dollar slice work. Now, Hanks has a line out the door. Hank makes the pizza. Co-Pilot handles the spreadsheets. Learn more at M-360. copilot.com slash work. Is contingency management usually offered together with other treatments? I mean, you mentioned some things that you can do with smoking, but if we're talking about
补充内容。我只想补充一点，这是一个极好的描述，我100%同意。我认为我们在兴奋剂成瘾治疗中面临的主要挑战是，我们提供的绝大多数干预措施都不是循证的。所以它们通常不是认知行为疗法。它们通常是其他类型的教育和其他编程。根据我从事这方面工作15年的经验，我们有很多人来到权变管理，他们尝试过住院项目。他们尝试过门诊项目。他们因为物质使用进过监狱或看守所。他们尝试过很多事情。无论出于什么原因，这个方法真的很管用。
people who are on amphetamine and opioids, does something like cognitive behavioral therapy help, or is it fine all by itself? It can go both ways. Certainly, contingency management can be offered on its own and doesn't require also providing psychotherapy, for example, like cognitive behavioral therapy. and in trials where we've looked at it alongside cognitive behavioral therapy, it just improves outcomes. So this is a case where it's not contraindicated. We've also looked at this, not Dr. McDonald and myself personally. The field has looked at this if our medications for opioid use disorder. And again, contingency management improves on outcomes.
因此，正如考格林博士所说，我们确实转向了这种说法，我转向了这样的表述：“优先考虑权变管理”。因此在阿片类药物领域，我们谈论的是药物辅助治疗（medication-assisted treatment）。这就是必须将药物添加到正在进行的其他人心理社会服务中的地方。但研究证据确实表明，起作用的是药物。如果你有需要帮助的其他问题，那些其他事情就很棒，我们也应该提供它们。我真的认为权变管理也是如此。我想强调一下考格林博士做的一些非常棒的工作，
And when we talk about opioid use, medications for opioid use disorder are our first line treatment, just like contingency management is our first line treatment for stimulant use disorder. So the recommendation I would be like, of course, medications for opioid use disorder, and contingency management in addition, helpful. When it comes to stimulants, the recommendation I would give is contingency management is what we should definitely have in the mix. Adding cognitive behavioral therapy is amazing. People like your learning skills to manage stress and to manage problematic thoughts, that's a great
如果我把细节搞错了，我很抱歉。但再次退一步讲，对于丁丙诺啡和阿片类药物，我们知道如果给一个人开具丁丙诺啡处方，他们死亡的可能性比患有阿片类药物障碍但没有使用的人低50%。因此，多年来我们一直在寻找，我们一直在希望有人能发表一项研究，其结论类似于权变管理。因此，考格林博士和她的团队与退伍金管理局（VA）合作，能够证明这一点——我要么会稍微弄错细节，所以我道歉——但在退伍金管理局系统中，真正接受了权变管理的患有兴奋剂使用障碍的人的死亡率降低了大约40%。
thing to add in addition to reinforcing someone for the recovery-oriented behaviors. And I would just add that's wonderful, a wonderful description and 100% agree. I think the main challenge we have in addiction treatment for stimulants is most of the interventions we offer are not evidence-based. So they're not cognitive behavioral therapy often. They're often other kinds of education and other programming. And in my experience from doing this for 15 years is that we have a lot of people who come to contingency management and they've tried inpatient programs. They've tried outpatient programs. They've been in prison or jail because of their substance use. And they've tried so many things. And for whatever reason, this really works.
所以我们不仅可以说它有效，可以帮助人们减少使用并帮助人们实现目标，它还能拯救人们的生命。我认为这就是我们在谈论这场危机、看到不断演变的危机（包括其中涉及兴奋剂）时，提供这一点是如此至关重要，因为我们看到了这些令人惊叹的、挽救生命的成效。我想你也许可以补充这一点，因为我的理解是，在一年多的时间里，他们死于兴奋剂或过量的可能性更小，对吧？这就是我们正在谈论的。你完全正确。
and so we've really moved towards the, as Dr. Coggan saying, we sort of move towards, I've moved towards the statement of like contingency management first. So in the opioid field, we talk about medication-assisted treatment. And that is where the medication has to be added to an ongoing other psychosocial services. But the research evidence really suggests it's the medication that works. And those other things are great if you have other issues that you need help with, and we should offer them. and I really am seeing that for contingency management as well. And I would just to highlight some really great work that Dr. Coglin's done,
所以在退伍金管理局，他们的权变管理模式是一个为期三个月的模式。因此这表明，对于患有兴奋剂使用障碍的人，我们观察了那些确实接受了权变管理的人和那些没有接受但在同一地点就诊的人（即两者都有机会潜在地接受权变管理）。那些接受了治疗的人随后被追踪了一年。我们还追踪了那些没有接受治疗的人。我们看到，正如麦克唐纳博士总结得非常好的那样，接受权变管理的人死亡的可能性更小，死亡率降低的幅度与患有阿片类药物障碍的人接受阿片类药物治疗时所看到的幅度相似。
if I get the details wrong, I'm sorry. But to take a step back again with buprenorphine and opioids, we know that if a person is prescribed buprenorphine, they're 50% less likely to die than a person with opioid disorders and not. And so we've been looking for years, we've been hoping someone just could publish a study that said something similar to contingency management. And so Dr. Coglin and her team, working with the VA, were able to show that, and I'm going to get it slightly wrong, so I apologize. But 40%, that mortality was reduced about 40 percent in people who had a stimulant use disorder who really received contingency management in the VA system.
如果我细节记错了，我很抱歉。但退一步讲，关于丁丙诺啡和阿片类药物，我们知道，如果一个人被处方了丁丙诺啡，他们的死亡率比患有阿片类药物障碍但没有使用该药的人低50%。因此，多年来我们一直在寻找，一直希望有人能发表一项研究，其结论类似于应急管理。因此，科格林博士和她的团队与退伍军人事务部（VA）合作，成功地证明了这一点——我可能会说得有点出入，所以我先道歉。但在VA系统中，对于接受应急管理的确诊兴奋剂使用障碍患者，其死亡率降低了大约40%。
So not only can we say it works and helps people reduce their use and helps people reach their goals, but it also saves people's lives. And I think that's what, as we talk about this crisis and we see the evolving crisis and including that it includes stimulants. that it's so essential that we offer this because we're seeing these amazing, you know, life-saving impacts. And I think you could maybe add to that because my understanding is that this is over the course of a year, they're less likely to die from stimulant from an overdose, right? That's what we're talking about. You're exactly right.
因此，我们不仅可以说它有效，还能帮助人们减少使用并实现他们的目标，它还能拯救人们的生命。我认为，当我们讨论这场危机、看到不断演变的危机（包括涉及兴奋剂的危机）时，提供这一点至关重要，因为我们看到了这些令人惊叹的、挽救生命的效果。我想你可以对此补充一点，因为我的理解是，在一年的时间里，他们死于兴奋剂过量的可能性更小，对吧？这就是我们所讨论的。你完全说对了。
So in the VA, their contingency management model is a three-month model. So what this shows is that for people that had a stimulant news disorder, We looked at folks that did receive contingency management and folks that didn't seen at the same place. So both having opportunity to potentially receive contingency management. And those who received it then followed them for a year. And we also followed those folks who didn't receive it. And we see that those who received contingency management, whereas Dr. McDonald-Berry did a great job summarizing, we're less likely to die, less likely to die in a similar magnitude of what we see for someone receiving medication for opioid use disorder when they have opioid use disorder.
所以在VA，他们的应急管理模型是一个为期三个月的模型。因此，这表明对于患有兴奋剂使用障碍的人，我们观察了确实接受应急管理的人以及在同一地点就诊但未接受该管理的人。因此，这两组人都有机会获得应急管理。那些接受了管理的人随后被追踪了一年，我们同时也追踪了那些没有接受管理的人。正如麦克唐纳-贝里博士总结得很好的那样，我们发现接受应急管理的人死亡可能性更小，其死亡率下降的幅度与患有阿片类药物使用障碍的人接受阿片类药物使用障碍药物治疗时所看到的降幅相似。
So we're reducing all-cause deaths, so dying for any reason. We're also reducing overdose deaths, so fewer overdose deaths and fewer deaths with stimulant involvement. So sort of seeing a pretty clear signal there that in sort of our gold standard signal in the addiction treatment field, because this is pretty hard to see to actually change death outcomes, that contingency management is quite literally able to save lives, which really helps to underscore sort of the public health message that we have here that I really relate to what Dr. McDonald is sharing, that, you know, contingency management really is what we need to have on board for people with stimulant use disorder because we have a life-saving solution. And it is as a field and as providers our job to make sure that this is available widely. And just to talk in practical terms,
所以我们正在减少全因死亡，也就是因任何原因导致的死亡。我们还在减少过量服用导致的死亡，也就是减少过量用药死亡以及含有兴奋剂成分的死亡人数。所以在某种程度上，我们在成瘾治疗领域中看到了一个非常清晰的“黄金标准”信号，因为要实际改变死亡结果是非常困难的，这表明权变管理确实能够字面意义上拯救生命。这真正有助于强调我们在此传达的公共卫生信息，这与麦克唐纳博士分享的内容非常契合，也就是，你知道，权变管理确实是我们针对兴奋剂使用障碍患者所需要采取的措施，因为我们拥有一个能挽救生命的解决方案。而作为整个行业和医疗服务提供者，我们的工作就是确保这种疗法得到广泛应用。从实际层面来讲，
so the way that this works is that a patient will come into the place where, you know, contingency management is being offered and will give a urine sample. Now, how do you, always guarantee that you're getting the urine sample of the person who's coming in and participating. And then if it's negative, you get a certain amount of money. If it's positive, they're not punished, right? I mean, they may get less money, but you don't say you lose, go away. Yeah, that's a great question. One of our colleagues that Dr. Coglin and I work with and is a part of my team says we're flipping the script on urine testing. Urine testing has been used as a way to catch people when they, relapse. And if you think about that, like any other disease, if you have a bad outcome,
这种方法的运作方式是，患者来到提供权变管理的场所，并提供一份尿样。那么，你如何确保每次都能拿到前来参与的那个人的尿样呢？如果检测结果呈阴性，你就会得到一定金额的奖励。如果呈阳性，他们也不会受到惩罚，对吧？我的意思是，他们可能会拿到较少的钱，但你不会说“你失败了，走吧”。是的，这是一个很好的问题。我们的同事之一——科格林博士和我共事并作为我团队成员的这位同事说，我们正在颠覆尿检的传统模式。过去，尿检一直被用作在人们复吸时抓包的工具。如果你仔细想想，就像其他任何疾病一样，如果你得到了一个糟糕的结果，
we don't say, hey, it's your fault. You may experience some shame, you know, if you're not managing your diabetes or your goals to lose weight or something. But it's not, you know, in addiction, we set it up to be these measures, these wonderful measures that allow us to objectively know if a person's meeting their goals or not, we've used them to hurt people. We've used them to put people down to make them feel shame. So in contingency management, we sort of shape, Mark, my colleague says, flip the script. We flip the script on urine testing. We actually don't follow people down the hall and observe their urine tests.
我们并不会说：“嘿，这是你的错。”如果你没有控制好糖尿病、没有达到减重目标或遇到类似情况，你可能会感到一些羞耻。但这并不是说，你知道，在成瘾治疗中，我们把这些指标——这些本该让我们客观了解一个人是否达成目标的绝妙指标——变成了伤害人们的工具。我们用它们来贬低人们，让他们感到羞耻。因此，在权变管理中，正如我的同事马克所说，我们颠覆了这种模式。我们颠覆了传统的尿检方式。我们实际上并不会尾随人们走进走廊并监督他们的尿检过程。
We want to treat people with respect and dignity and in a positive way. And so we hand them a urine test. They run down, they walk down, give the sample. They come back. We aren't foolish. So we do do things like, you know, we test the temperature of the urine. There are things you might never want to be interested in it. Things I never thought when I was in graduate school I'd ever talk about.
我们希望以尊重、尊严和积极的方式对待人们。所以我们把尿杯递给他们。他们跑过去，走过去，留下样本。然后他们回来。我们并不愚蠢。所以我们确实会做一些事情，比如，你知道，我们会测试尿液的温度。有些事情你可能永远都不想去了解。有些事情我在读研究生时从没想过自己会在
on a podcast. So we do some simple things like that because they're cheap and inexpensive and they kind of come with the product. And we don't want to set people up to be tempted to, you know, to mislead us. But sometimes people have to unlearn that. They have to just unlearn the fact that they sort of have the shocking look on their face. Like when we say, oh, yeah, your results positive. You know, keep trying.
播客节目中谈论。所以我们会做一些这样简单的事情，因为它们成本低廉且随产品附带。我们不想让人产生作弊或误导我们的念头。但有时人们需要改掉这种固有观念。他们需要摆脱那种当听到我们说“哦，是的，你的结果呈阳性，没关系，继续加油”时，脸上露出的震惊表情。
Let's come back in a couple days and let's try again. Or how can we help you? Who can help you, you know, work on this? And they're sort of shocked at first because they're like, oh, you're not going to yell at me or you're not going to, you know, say, hey, you're not meeting your treatment goals or you're not going to call my parole probation officer. We're like, no, come back again, try again. And so that positive encouraging repeated chances for success, the two times a week, the reason we do it two times a week is because people can come back and they can, if they don't make it one week, they can try one day, they can try again the next day. And when they try and they get that first incentive, you've seen that their face light up is amazing.
“过几天回来，我们再试一次。或者我们能怎么帮你？谁能帮你度过难关？”他们一开始会感到震惊，因为他们会想：“哦，你们不会对我大喊大叫，不会说‘嘿，你没有达到治疗目标’，也不会给我的假释或缓刑官打电话吗？”而我们会说：“不，再来一次，继续尝试。”这种积极、鼓励、重复的成功机会，一周两次——我们之所以安排一周两次，是因为人们可以不断回来，如果这一周没能做到，他们可以在某一天尝试，第二天还可以再试。当他们尝试并获得了第一笔奖励时，你会看到他们的脸上绽放出惊人的光彩。
And the high fives you get and the smiles. And that's really, you know, really wonderful. and then that momentum builds with the incentives. So we really try to treat people with the respect and dignity and accountability that we expect. And we also recognize that, you know, this isn't as high stakes as whether or not you're going to go to jail or you're going to lose your kids if you test positive for a drug test here or you're going to get kicked out of the NBA. You know, really, this is a $10 gift card and most people, you know, are very respectful about that. And if a person does try to pull one over on us, we just don't see that. for that sort of level of incentives we give out.
你击掌庆祝，看到他们的笑容，这真的非常美妙。接着，这种动力会随着奖励的增加而累积。因此，我们真的努力以我们所期望的尊重、尊严和责任感来对待人们。我们也认识到，这并不像在这里的药物检测呈阳性就要坐牢、失去抚养权或者被NBA开除那样风险极高。你知道，实际上，这只是一张10美元的礼品卡，大多数人对此都非常尊重。如果有人确实想在我们这里蒙混过关，鉴于我们发放的这种级别的奖励，我们其实并未发现这种情况。
How long do these interventions typically last? And then what happens to people when the incentives end? I like to frame this like any of our treatments, like our therapy treatments and our medication treatments. And so we think about in the space of addiction, we provide a treatment and we're for contingency management. We provide typically a three to six-month intervention. And then we actually have,
这些干预措施通常会持续多久？当奖励结束时，人们会怎么样？我喜欢像看待我们的任何其他治疗方法（如心理疗法和药物治疗）那样来构架这一点。因此，在成瘾治疗领域，我们提供一种治疗，而我们支持权变管理。我们通常会提供为期三到六个月的干预。然后实际上，
there's a really great meta-analysis that came out by Gindley at all. a few years back, and it actually showed that among studies, multiple studies with contingency management and with other types of interventions tested as well, once we stop the interventions, yes, I want to be like clear, just like when we stop cognitive behavioral therapy or medication, you see some return to use among people that use stimulants. And for those that receive contingency management, you see less of that than you do for other types of interventions. So actually people, you stop the intervention, and more people than you'd expect are actually just
几年前吉恩德利（Gindley）等人发表了一篇非常棒的荟萃分析，它实际上显示，在各项研究中——包括多项关于权变管理的研究以及测试的其他类型的干预措施——一旦我们停止干预，是的，我想说清楚，就像当我们停止认知行为疗法或药物治疗时一样，在使用兴奋剂的人群中，你会看到一定程度的复吸。而对于接受权变管理的人来说，这种复吸情况比其他类型的干预要少。因此，实际上，当你停止干预时，比你预期更多的人其实都在
continuing doing well, and this really gets at a key misconception in the contingency management space, this idea that, you know, the myth that because people are only not using because you're giving them these relatively modest rewards. And this is just entirely not panning out when we look at the data because we find both what patients tell us is like, this is consistent with their goals. Most people do not want to be using methamphetamine if they're experiencing a methamphetamine use disorder. It's a really pretty miserable time for them. And so they want to be stopping use. And you find that, you find, If you can help people scaffold them to have some success there, then the incentives end, when the intervention ends,
继续保持良好状态。这真正切中了权变管理领域的一个核心误解，即这种神话：人们之所以不再吸毒，仅仅是因为你给了他们这些相对微薄的奖励。当我们查看数据时，这种说法完全站不住脚，因为我们发现，正如患者告诉我们的那样，这符合他们的目标。如果正经历甲基苯丙胺（冰毒）使用障碍，大多数人其实并不想吸毒。这对他们来说是一段非常痛苦的经历。因此，他们希望停止使用。你会发现，如果你能帮助人们建立支持系统并取得一些成功，那么当奖励结束、干预结束时，
folks actually more than not don't return to use and have started getting reinforcers from other things in their lives. So that time where they weren't using during the contingency management intervention might have given them a time to get a job to make progress on getting their kids back, to make progress in the legal system, such that they're starting to experience reinforcers from reengaging with family, from other things that actually serve to support their ongoing recovery. So there really two takeaways there.
大多数人实际上并没有复吸，并且开始从生活中的其他事物中获得正向强化。因此，在权变管理干预期间他们没有吸毒的那段时间里，可能为他们提供了一段找工作、在争取夺回孩子抚养权方面取得进展、在法律系统中取得进展的时间，从而使他们开始体验到来自重新融入家庭以及其他事物的正向强化，这些都有助于支持他们持续康复。所以这里真正有两个关键结论。
One being, contingency management long-term outcomes after intervention are as good or better than our other stimulant use disorder treatment interventions, and tend towards better. And also contingency management, the rewards we're giving people in contingency management are really just the early rewards to helping people engage with more robust rewards that actually keep many of us from not going into using substances regularly, right? those family and jobs and things that we're trying to reengage folks with. Thinking about expanding access, since these programs clearly work, can CM interventions ever be done virtually, or do people always have to come in for an in-person test?
其一是，干预结束后，权变管理的长期效果与我们其他的兴奋剂使用障碍治疗干预措施一样好甚至更好，并且有更好的趋势。其二是，我们在权变管理中给予人们的奖励，其实只是帮助人们接触到更强大奖励的早期奖励——正是这些强大的奖励阻止了我们大多数人经常去使用物质，对吧？也就是我们正试图让人们重新融入的家庭和工作等事物。考虑到扩大获取途径，既然这些程序显然有效，那么CM干预措施是否可以通过虚拟方式进行，还是说人们必须亲自来做现场检测？
So, yeah, as I mentioned before, we're doing a virtual study. And I'm only doing the virtual study because of the pandemic. We had an in-person study that was actually supposed to be done in permanent support of housing where we thought, hey, people can't come into the clinic. two times a week. Let's offer it at their home. And so we started with that. And as soon as we recruited our first participant to that study, we found that, the pandemic hit. The pandemic hit. And we had to pivot. And so we developed a virtual version of this where folks come in and they submit a blood test. And we just observed them. They do a collection on their, on their shoulder here.
所以，是的，正如我之前提到的，我们正在做一项虚拟研究。我开展虚拟研究纯粹是因为大流行。我们原本有一项面对面的研究，原本计划在永久支持性住房中进行，当时我们认为，嘿，人们一周不能来诊所两次，不如我们在他们家里提供这项服务。于是我们从这开始。而就在我们为该研究招募了第一位参与者时，大流行爆发了。大流行爆发了。我们不得不做出调整。因此，我们开发了一个虚拟版本，人们可以在其中提交血液检测样本。我们只是观察他们。他们在自己的肩膀上进行采集。
And then they did the easy blood sample and they mail it off. And then if it's negative, they get an incentive sent to them via text and a gift card incentive. And that's worked wonderfully. And again, I mentioned only 25% of people in that study are saying they ever had treatment for alcohol use to serve before. So we're reaching 75% of the folks coming to that study are coming and have never received any intervention before. And many of them talk about how interested they were. And this I think fits an overall health care trend, a virtual delivery of other health care modalities. Really, they're emphasizing that virtual piece is why they're doing it.
然后他们完成简单的血液样本采集并将其邮寄出去。如果检测结果呈阴性，他们会通过短信收到一份奖励以及一份礼品卡奖励。这取得了极佳的效果。再次重申，我提到在该研究中只有25%的人表示以前曾接受过酒精使用障碍的治疗。因此我们触及了75%来到该研究的参与者，他们以前从未接受过任何干预。他们中的许多人谈到他们对此有多么感兴趣。我认为这符合整体医疗保健趋势，即其他医疗保健模式的虚拟化交付。他们确实在强调，虚拟化正是他们这样做的原因。
We have another study that we just wrapped up where we're and other people are doing work like this, where we have a breathalizer, again, for alcohol. And so a person blows in a little breathalyzer and they take a picture of a selfie. Then we have facial recognition software that verifies it that person. And if they have a negative sample three times a day, then they get an incentive every day.
我们刚刚结束了另一项研究，其他研究人员也在做类似的工作，我们在其中使用酒精呼气测力计。因此，个人吹气到一个小型呼气测力计中并拍摄一张自拍照。然后我们拥有面部识别软件来验证该人的身份。如果他们的样本一天三次呈阴性，他们每天都会获得奖励。
And we've just analyzed the results of those. They aren't published yet, but they are pretty amazing and consistent with our other work. So we're really trying to figure out ways to sort of really address those barriers, in particular that come in two times a week to a clinic is a challenge.
我们刚刚分析了这些结果。它们尚未发表，但非常惊人，并且与我们的其他工作保持一致。所以我们真的在想方设法解决这些障碍，特别是每周去诊所两次这一挑战。
And also some people, especially when you move into the smoking cessation space or alcohol treatment space, they don't want to go into an addiction treatment clinic. They might feel like that's too stigmatizing for them or it's not a place that they maybe are interested in. So I think that that's definitely been a space where there's a lot of exciting work happening. Dr. Coughlin, you wanted to jump in there. Yeah, I'll just add to what Dr. McDonald said here. So one thing within the digital contingency management space that we've found really interesting is that there might be an opportunity to reduce sort of the burden for patients to engage in contingency management. I would say, well, the biggest
还有一些人，特别是当你进入戒烟领域或酒精治疗领域时，他们不想走进成瘾治疗诊所。他们可能会觉得那对他们来说带有太强的污名化色彩，或者那不是他们可能感兴趣的地方。因此，我认为这绝对是一个正在进行许多令人兴奋的工作的领域。科格林博士，你想要插话。是的，我只想补充一点麦克唐纳博士刚才所说的话。因此，在数字权变管理领域，我们发现非常有趣的一点是，可能存在一个机会来减轻患者参与权变管理的负担。我想说，目前权变管理面临的最大
challenge that's facing contingency management right now is making sure that we really are getting it to people and to the majority of people. For this to have an impact, it can't be a bespoke model that only a very, very few people ever receive. Whether we're talking about smoking, drinking, stimulants, opioids, we really need it to be something that's widely available. There's been so much work done in the addiction space and the mental health space broadly to think how we get evidence-based care into population health settings. And digital is, I'd say, one important tool for that. So we do some work with tobacco use, providing an app-based experience, but making sure that we still have it interfacing with clinicians or coaches, because for many people, as Dr. McDonald did a wonderful job,
挑战是确保我们真正将它提供给人们以及绝大多数人。要产生影响，它不能是一个只有极少数人才能获得的定制模式。无论我们谈论的是吸烟、饮酒、兴奋剂还是阿片类药物，我们真的需要让它成为一种广泛可用的服务。在成瘾领域和更广泛的精神卫生领域，人们已经做了大量工作来思考如何将循证护理引入群体健康设置中。数字化可以说是一个重要的工具。因此，我们围绕烟草使用做了一些工作，提供基于应用程序的体验，但确保它仍然与临床医生或教练进行交互，因为对许多人来说，正如麦克唐纳博士出色地
sort of exemplifying, especially if they're having trouble with initial, not using initially, having positive samples, that relationship, that interaction with the clinician is so key, is so reinforcing, working towards that early success, that high five is really, really important. So my personal thinking on this currently is there is definitely a space for digital contingency management, and we need to be thinking about how that interfaces with what is really important, again, to us as humans and also reinforcing, which is connecting with someone in that sense of belonging. And so I think that these two pieces are really coming together in the science. And also there's some companies out there that are doing really forward-thinking work thinking about
展示的那样，特别是如果他们在最初的戒毒或初始阶段遇到困难、出现阳性样本时，这种关系、与临床医生的这种互动是如此关键，如此具有正向强化作用，朝着早期的成功而努力，那种击掌庆祝真的非常非常重要。因此，我目前对此的个人看法是，数字权变管理绝对有一席之地，我们需要思考它如何与对我们人类而言同样重要且具有正向强化作用的事物相交互，也就是与某人建立联系以及那种归属感。因此，我认为这两部分在科学上真正融合在了一起。此外，还有一些公司正在做极具前瞻性的工作，思考
how we can build models of digital contingency management that both have fidelity to these key mechanisms of contingency management, incentive magnitudes that are meaningful to people, frequency of testing and getting incentives to people right away so they feel that the reward really is counterbalancing the reinforcing effects of the drug, but doing so in a way that is really scalable. And so I think that it's an exciting time in that space because we're really thinking about how can we reach people, whether they live in the UP of Michigan or in Seattle, and make sure that they're getting access across the board to the treatments of work. So I just want to wrap up by asking you both about the biggest challenges in getting CM to all the people who would benefit from it.
我们如何才能建立数字权变管理模型，使其既能忠实于权变管理的核心机制（对人们有意义的奖励幅度、检测频率并立即向人们发放奖励，让他们觉得奖励确实抵消了药物的正向强化效应），又能以真正可扩展的方式进行。因此，我认为这是该领域一个令人兴奋的时期，因为我们真正在思考如何能够触及人们，无论他们住在密歇根州的上半岛还是西雅图，并确保他们能够全面获得起作用的治疗。因此，我最后想问你们两个关于将CM推广给所有能从中受益的人时所面临的最大挑战是什么。
Because what I hear you're saying is it's proven to be effective. We've got the evidence. It's been tested since 2011, you said was when the VA C.M. started working on this, and yet it's not available in every community to all the people who need it. So where are the stumbling blocks? I'll start out, and then Dr. McDonald could have lost word here. So it's multifactor, as it always is. So I'd say we've made incredible progress in the policy space, and we've also made a lot of progress in the payer space. For a long time, the reasons everyone said we didn't have wide enough scale contingency management were that we hadn't figure out
因为我听到你们说它已被证明是有效的。我们有证据。它自2011年以来一直在接受测试——你提到那是退伍军人事务部（VA）开始开展C.M.工作的时间——然而它并没有在每个社区向所有需要它的人提供。那么，绊脚石在哪里呢？我先开始，然后麦克唐纳博士可以做最后的总结。所以，正如以往一样，这是多因素的。因此，我想说我们在政策领域取得了令人难以置信的进展，我们在支付方领域也取得了很大进展。长期以来，每个人都说我们没有足够大规模推广权变管理的理由是，我们还没有弄清楚
how to pay for it at scale, which we're doing right now through demonstration, projects through state funds in many cases. Like we're cracking that nut, which is really incredible. And I'd also say, can you mention the SAMHSA advisory that came out, sort of the federal communication of like we are behind meaningful amounts of incentives to make sure that this is available really helps to alleviate some hesitation that we were seeing from the policy side of getting this out. So that was a really, really big progress. To me, the biggest challenges we're facing is thinking through how we are going to do this across a really varied substance use disorder treatment infrastructure. And it takes, I think, a couple things. One, it takes a lot of focus on
如何在宏观上为之付费——而我们现在通过许多州的示范项目和州基金正在做到这一点。就像我们正在攻克这个难题一样，这真的非常了不起。我还想说，你可以提及美国联邦物质滥用和精神健康服务管理局（SAMHSA）发布的咨询意见，这是一种联邦层面的沟通，表明我们支持提供大量的激励措施以确保其真正可用，这确实有助于缓解我们在推动政策落地时看到的一些迟疑。所以这真的是一个非常非常大的进步。对我来说，我们面临的最大挑战是思考如何在高度多样化的物质使用障碍治疗基础设施中开展这项工作。我认为这需要几点。首先，它需要高度关注
developing our contingency management champions, right? And this means people across all levels. You're talking to Dr. McDonald and I, but there are a lot of people that care deeply about our addiction care, making sure that we are developing people that are going to champion this within clinics, within Department of Health, within our states, within our federal agencies. So that's one real key. I think we're working hard on. The other piece that I focus a lot on is that contingency management is not necessarily accessible to everyone when we do it in clinic. So what we've alluded to a little bit is this idea of coming to a clinic twice a week when we're talking about sort of the biggest place we need contingency management right now is stimulant use disorder. That doesn't work if you have a lot of child care responsibilities. If you live more than 10 miles from a clinic, if you don't have regular access to transportation. And so we really need to be thinking about how we can lower barriers for people to receive contingency management across all sorts of who are living all sorts of different lives.
培养我们的权变管理倡导者，对吧？这意味着各个层面的倡导者。你在和麦克唐纳博士和我对话，但有许多人深深关心我们的成瘾护理，我们需要确保培养出能够在诊所内、卫生部门内、各州以及联邦机构内倡导这一疗法的人。这是关键的一点，我认为我们正在为此努力。我关注的另一个重点是，当我们在诊所进行权变管理时，它并不一定对每个人都容易获得。因此，我们略微提及的一个想法是，当我们需要权变管理的最主要领域是兴奋剂使用障碍时，一周去诊所两次是行不通的。如果你有很多照顾孩子的责任；如果你住在距离诊所10英里以外的地方；如果你没有常规的交通方式，这就行不通。因此，我们真正需要思考的是，如何为生活在各种不同生活环境中的人们降低接受权变管理的障碍。
And so we've thought a lot about this in the opioid use disorder space. And I think we can learn a lot when we think about how to lower barriers to make sure that people that have stimulant use disorders are able to receive contingency management equally. Thank you, Dr. Coggan. I would just add, because I'm sitting in my office here, here, and I remember sitting here six years ago, and I just met with a reporter about, and she asked why isn't contingency management we used outside of the VA? And she just wanted to meet with one client who had a stimulant use disorder who wasn't being
我们在阿片类药物使用障碍领域对此进行了很多思考。我认为当我们思考如何降低障碍以确保兴奋剂使用障碍患者能够平等获得权变管理时，我们可以学到很多东西。谢谢你，科格林博士。我只想补充一点，因为我正坐在我的办公室里，我记得六年前我坐在那里，我刚刚见了一位记者，她问为什么权变管理不在退伍军人事务部（VA）之外使用？她只想见一位患有兴奋剂使用障碍但未得到
served by the VA, and we couldn't, a bunch of us experts that are outside the VA couldn't find a single person. We couldn't find one person that she could talk to. And I'd sat in my office, and I was depressed. I was like, what's the point? I didn't sign up to be a researcher and develop treatments that aren't being used. So I had a personal goal of just trying to figure out why the heck is this going on? Because I've had lots of, until that point, most of the feedback I'd get about why contingency
VA服务患者，而我们做不到，我们这群VA之外的专家找不到哪怕一个人。我们甚至找不到一个她可以交谈的人。我坐在办公室里，感到沮丧。我想，这有什么意义？我当研究人员并开发未被使用的治疗方法可不是为了这个。因此，我当时有一个个人目标，就是想弄清楚这到底是怎么回事？因为在此之前，关于为什么权变
management shouldn't happen or isn't happening is because it was immoral. People shared their moral concerns about it. You know, why are you paying people to stop using drugs? And we'll often see a story about contingency manager with that headline, which is unfortunate. So that's sort of stigma around the intervention. But really, once I started learning about this, I learned it. It was actually not that at all. It was the funding piece.
管理不应该发生或没有发生，我收到的大多数反馈都是因为它是不道德的。人们分享了他们对它的道德担忧。你知道，为什么要付钱让人停止吸毒？我们经常会看到以这个标题报道权变管理的文章，这很不幸。因此，这就是围绕这种干预措施的污名化。但事实上，当我开始了解这方面时，我发现根本不是那么回事。问题出在资金上。
This is not a talk therapy. This is not a medication. So there's really not a practical way to pay for it. And that's why the VA has been so successful because their healthcare system is organized in a different way than the out sort of the rest of our healthcare systems for the most part in the United States. And so you all were able to overcome that.
这不是谈话疗法。这不是药物治疗。因此，确实没有一种切实可行的方法来为之付费。这就是为什么VA如此成功，因为他们的医疗系统在组织方式上与美国其他大部分地区的医疗系统有所不同。因此，你们能够克服这一点。
And then also there's amazing things that you were able to do inside the VA to really fundraise and get leadership support to pay for it. So the changes we mentioned about, the SAMHSA changes are wonderful, and we need to keep working on those funding to have multiple ways to fund this intervention and to have like a billing code for contingency management, which doesn't exist. The other reason, though, and I think the bigger reason, is regulatory. And I absolutely did never want to learn about this. I didn't want to learn about urine testing, like I said, but I also didn't want to learn about regulatory and taxes and things like that.
而且，你们在VA内部还能够做出令人惊叹的事情，进行筹款并获得领导层的支持来为之付费。因此，我们提到的变化——SAMHSA的变化非常棒，我们需要继续致力于这些资金筹措，以拥有多种资助该干预措施的途径，并且拥有一个目前尚不存在的权变管理的计费代码。不过，另一个原因，也是我认为更重要的原因，是监管方面的。我绝对从来不想了解这些。正如我所说，我不想了解尿检，但我同样不想了解监管、税收之类的事情。
So, you know, in general, it's prohibited to give a Medicaid, a patient who's care is funded by Medicaid money. And there's been a lot of fraud outside of the addiction space. There's been a lot of fraud, billions of dollars of fraud over the last 20 years, where providers would provide an incentive like a gift card to somebody to come in for a health screening. And they'd run up all these medically unnecessary tests. And so the federal government has good reasons to be concerned across all administrations that that's happening. And they don't want that to happen. And so until the end of the first Trump administration, there really was a prohibition against contingency management in the funded space outside of the VA. And so what we've really worked hard on, and this is where I'm
所以，总的来说，禁止向医疗补助计划（Medicaid）资助医疗费用的患者提供奖励。在成瘾治疗领域之外发生过很多欺诈行为。在过去20年里，曾发生过大量欺诈行为，涉及数十亿美元，当时医疗服务提供者向某人提供诸如礼品卡之类的奖励，吸引他们前来做健康筛查。然后他们进行了所有这些医学上不必要的检查。因此，联邦政府在各个行政部门都有充分的理由担心这种情况发生，他们不希望这种情况发生。因此，直到第一届特朗普政府结束之前，在VA之外的受资助领域，确实存在对权变管理的禁令。所以我们真正努力去做的事情——这也是我作为心理学家为我们感到
really proud of us as psychologists, is that the team who's really, who's led this work, really led by Dr. Rick Rosson and many others, are all, and there are many allied professionals part of this, but really it's been a psychologist-led effort to advocate for the funding and policy reforms that are needed. And so we're at a point now where the demonstration, Medicaid demonstration waygivers that Dr. Coggin was mentioning really offer one way to get that regulatory approval. And There's other rules that we're learning more about and we're hoping that we get more clarity from the federal government on those rules. But really that regulatory barrier is still our biggest challenge in terms of people really do not want to be subject to Medicaid fraud investigation. The word fraud, waste, and abuse is terrifying to people.
无比自豪的地方，是由里克·罗森（Rick Rosson）博士及许多其他人真正领导的团队推动了这项工作，当然还有许多联合专业人员参与其中，但这确实是一项由心理学家主导的努力，旨在倡导所需的资金和政策改革。因此，我们现在处于这样一个阶段：科格林博士提到的Medicaid示范豁免确实提供了一种获得监管批准的途径。我们还在了解其他一些规则，并希望从联邦政府获得关于这些规则的更多清晰信息。但实际上，就人们真的不想成为Medicaid欺诈调查的目标而言，监管障碍仍然是我们最大的挑战。欺诈、浪费和滥用（fraud, waste, and abuse）这个词对人们来说太可怕了。
We know contingency management is not fraud, waste, and abuse. The federal government's been very clear on that. But feeling comfortable and willing to implement it and having the regulatory approvals to do it is another thing. I think that's a big barrier. Well, Dr. Coughlin, Dr. MacDonald, I want to thank you both for joining me today and thank you for the important work that you're both doing. Thank you. Thanks so much for having us. This was really fun. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get podcasts.
我们知道权变管理不是欺诈、浪费和滥用。联邦政府对此已经非常明确。但要感到安心、愿意实施它并获得相应的监管批准则是另一回事。我认为这是一个巨大的障碍。好吧，科格林博士、麦克唐纳博士，我要感谢你们两人今天加入我的节目，并感谢你们俩正在做的重要工作。谢谢你们。非常感谢邀请我们。这真的很有趣。你可以在我们的网站 speakingof psychology.org 上找到《心理学聊天室》（Speaking of Psychology）以前的节目，也可以在苹果、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方收听。
And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us. us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢听到的内容，请订阅并留下评论。如果你对未来的节目有任何意见或想法，你可以给我们发电子邮件。我们的邮箱是 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。《心理学聊天室》由李·温纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。感谢收听美国心理学会（American Psychological Association）的节目。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。